[Music]
hi everyone I'm near thar sake I'm a
site reliability engineer four ways
picking cloud provider is not an easy
task
and there is a perception that the cost
of switching providers is high I'm here
to show it's not always the case and
switching cloud providers is a doable
task with the right set of tools
procedures and measures for example we
migrated large portions of our system
from AWS into GCP in just a matter of
months with just a team of two people
how many of you use Waze today raise
your hands Wow okay thank you awesome
for those of you who are not familiar
with Waze we provide turn-by-turn
navigation with real-time traffic data
we currently have over 80 million active
users with an average usage of 582
minutes every month that's a lot of
traffic John you know I really love
working for ways I think it has an
amazing culture for engineering it's so
incredible to work on a product that
helps a lot of people on a daily basis
let's watch a quick clip on what ways
does for its users
when waves first launched its core was
about outsmarting traffic together
CCP is a next natural evolution of ways
now we're really talking about saving
time for millions of people our drivers
are out on the streets every hour of
every day reporting the most accurate
information on closures and congestion
we are taking that information and
delivering it to the government
officials who can address incidents in
real time this is a real program with
real impact we're actually sitting down
with partners and having measureable
results every day Boston is a city of
around 600,000 residents but during a
typical work day we grow to over a
million people
Waze has allowed us to rapidly iterate
through experiments to see what sort of
effects interventions have on congestion
and traffic we had a major snow last
March seeing the data come in from ways
every two minutes allows us to grab user
reports and then we can respond to those
reports in a timely manner
Genisys is a software company that
provides solutions to help first
responders by putting ways inside our
genesis product our first responders are
saving five minutes and that saves lives
we didn't expect that so quickly we
would have cities redistributing traffic
personnel that we would have 911 systems
relying on this data as more data comes
online Waze is proud to bring together
innovative transportation leaders from
all around the world to develop the next
chapter and traffic management at the
core is CCP has the same mission as a
ways which is to save people time every
day it's showing us what our new goals
are going to be new forms of safety and
new forms of urban mobility helping
cities become a lab for making lives
better
[Music]
all right so now that we understand what
we do in order to improve everyone's
lives let's take a second and look at
our scale what does it take to power up
ways to serve over 80 million users so
let's start with the basics each
front-end serving stack is behind a low
bouncer and has auto scaling enable you
know to shrink and grow as needed that
way we allow ourselves to have the
flexibility in terms of rush-hour or
save cost when it's middle of the night
and no one is driving on the data beside
we use Cassandra we have over 800 nodes
of Cassandra each cluster also contains
a memcache cell cluster that memcache is
used to store temporary data or
Cassandra Dahdah
because Cassandra is not the most
capable solution in terms of speed we
allow our memcache to store the data for
us to grow fast if needed we currently
have over a hundred micro services just
like this one each micro service is
spread across multiple availability
zones and across regions and the most
critical ones are even spread across
multiple providers Amazon and Google to
provide ourselves the best redundancy we
can for our users for internal
communications we have developed our own
discovery system and communication this
is done through a peer-to-peer system so
servers connect directly they do not
have any single point of failures or any
bottlenecks for traffic to power up all
these a hundred plus micro services and
Cassandra clusters and everything else
we currently have over 35,000 cores at
any given time growing out to double the
amount in case of rush hours
I hope you can see this is a very large
scale and such the thought of changing
providers is might be a crazy one even
you know who does that right but as one
of the folks who actually did a
migration I could say it's very easy
it's easier than you think it's very
interesting because most migration talks
you'll hear are either boolean either
this provider or dot a partial migration
lets you mix and match provider
solutions and you can decide to remain
split among providers long-term and you
can enjoy the benefit of both worlds at
the same time and experiment while you
do so for example in 2015 Amazon had an
outage that lasted eight hours this was
pre our DCP migration we wanted to spin
up our DCP cluster sooner than what we
wanted but sadly we couldn't do it just
because we weren't ready
our engineers work a lot of time to make
sure ways will not crash that day and
I'm happy to say we didn't but it was
very very close and this was one of the
triggers for us to actually realize we
actually need a multi cloud solution and
not just rely on one provider
so ways was acquired by Google in 2013
as you probably know now if you're owned
by a company who provides cloud services
it makes sense that we'll look at it and
not just say we'll stick with what we
have but doesn't mean that we'll
actually migrate to that if it doesn't
make sense we had that privilege of
picking ourselves what provider we want
to run and we weren't forced anything
upon us it's also very hard to choose a
provider you know one second I'm sorry
about this it's also very hard to choose
a provider because there are so many of
those and they look differently right
there's this cloud and even this cloud
and how about this pretty one and
there's even an actual cloud so how do
you choose one
so why GCP when you choose migrating to
another provider
I'm sorry so when you choose to switch
to another provider you have to set
yourselves some key points that you want
to do and because you have to measure
that and if you do not measure that how
do you know it's a successful move or if
it even makes sense for you to do that
in our case when we evaluate a GCP which
is that cost resilience and end user
performance is what matters to us so
let's take a look at each one of those
cost if you want to get the best price
for UVM and other providers you have to
reserve them in advance and figure out
how many you want to reserve because all
our system uses out of scaling that
number was never right
we're either underestimated or
overestimated doesn't matter how you
look at it we lost money not to mention
that this process was the very
time-consuming sadly I did it so I know
we wasted days of work every quarter
just to figure out what is that
percentage that we need to buy not to
mention that reserving an instance means
that you're locked into that one let's
say you have a new family being released
and you cpufamily you want to use that
so that you can't your start Friday one
year or three years what can you do or
maybe you have redesign your application
and now you actually don't need those
200 nodes of Cassandra and you actually
need free
in GCP we get that price out of the box
because GCP has automatic sustained use
count for us it made sense that all our
expensive workloads should move to GCP
as soon as we can because that will
lower our costs significantly next up we
have custom machine types for those of
you are not familiar with custom machine
types they allow you to pick any for any
flavor you want take X cores and X and
in Y memory and if you need add a few
locals as these but if you don't don't
add them each one you can do whatever
you want
at first it may not seem that special
but when you're dealing with a flood of
micro services it actually makes sense
you have to find that just balance
between cost and performance here on the
screen we can see an example of a
Cassandra cluster we have moved from
Amazon to Google that Cassandra cluster
had six nodes on Amazon side it was in I
2 for Excel which the underbanked price
for it is almost 2500 but we actually
pick that one just because we needed CPU
we didn't need all that local SSD we
also didn't need all that Ram but you
can't do anything with that because
that's what you get
we used custom VMs to exactly pick what
we needed we needed 20 virtual CPUs and
30 gigabytes of memory and just one
local SSD which in Google that 375
gigabytes as you can see the price
difference is huge now of course we
could reserve those instances in Amazon
but still you can see there is a huge
difference if you combine both of those
materials preserving instances and
custom VMs we have managed save way
over 20 percent every year just because
of those and that's a lot
the next metric we have was resilience
GC piece flat network provide us a
seamless cross region transport a VM can
communicate to a VM in the same region
just as easily as it can talk to another
region it you don't have to worry about
firewall rules external like piece
encryption or so forth it's as simple as
that
this is something we couldn't do in AWS
which prevented us from moving easily
into a multi region solution and lastly
we have latency Google's load balancer
is globally deployed in all these
locations giving the best latency and
performance for our end users this was a
critical path for us because ways
currently serves over 100 countries
worldwide it's not just us where you
want the best latency but you have to
care about those South America customers
orders APEC customers everyone matters
in our case for example let's echo
service that we've migrated into GCP
this servers basically loads up the map
that you see on the screen
whenever you use Waze you get those
images it's a very simple application
it's a standalone one that on the front
end it has nginx on the backend Tomcat
and it's being served by Cassandra and
memcache in order to have all tiles
cache their memcache currently has over
99% heat ratio because we don't change
the map every second which they change
it every day using the same design we
had in Amazon we have managed to improve
our latency by 10 percent that means 10
percent lower
latency for all our customers just by
moving we didn't do any change and just
like this service we have dozens more
that benefit this improvement
sorry about that once we've decided to
that we want migrate we have set
ourselves some principles on how we plan
to migrate first of all we wanted to
make sure what that we shield our
developers from this migration our team
destory team shouldn't make the
developer's job harder because it's more
efficient to run on GCP they should be
working and not stressful about the
migration that's not a healthy engineer
next you should always have an escape
plan in this case I'm not sure if he has
one in case we have any issues with a
migration we wanted to have a fast
rollback this gave us more confident in
going fast because we always knew
there's a way back we never let let it
go and lastly we're doing this for users
if we're impacting our users just
because we want to migrate there's no
reason to migrate let's say you guys are
finishing it long day at work
all you want to do is get home as
quickly as possible and making sure that
ways actually works for you otherwise
you might be stuck in a traffic jam and
you won't get home to spend time with
your family friends or just relax with
your favorite pet or maybe you want the
cuddly pet up to you but you want to get
home next up we decided on how we were
gonna migrate we need to design how we
will do this because we've set ourselves
some principles are fast rollback we
need a solution that we can run both
services at the same time we've decided
to use Amazon's and Google's managed VPN
solution it made sense out-of-the-box
solution why not sadly that didn't work
for us we quickly understood that
Amazon's VPN solution has some faults it
doesn't scale as much as we need and
when we transmit large amount of packets
it has also a lot of packet loss both
things we couldn't tolerate
we've sat down with Google engineers to
try and figure out what we can do so
we've built a solution that looks like
this on the Amazon side we've purchased
Derek connect fibers that basically go
into Equinix data center there we've
purchased Iraq that has off-the-shelf
VPN appliances multiple of those of
course for redundancy from those VPN
appliances we've established connection
to Google's managed VPN solution because
that one is capable and doesn't have any
issues this allowed us to have both
providers look like it's just one
provider fvm can talk to a VM just as it
talks to a VM it's in its own its region
and if it's in GCP it doesn't know it
has another IP address but for him it's
an internal IP it just works this later
has evolved into a managed solution that
Google is providing customers and it has
improved since we've designed this if
you guys want to use this you don't need
those VPN appliances Google solution
just allows you to take a fiber cable
from Amazon and from Google and connect
them and that's it that product is
called private in interconnect
so now that we have a reliable and the
low latency connectivity we could start
migrating our services but we needed to
come up with a way to achieve our other
principles how do we shield those
engineers from being frustrated because
we migrate they shouldn't care if it's
in Amazon or in Google they just want to
deploy their applications we've done a
lot of research and we found out that
spinnaker which is an open source
application developed by speed by
Netflix and maintained also by multiple
other companies is the right choice for
us spinnaker supports multi cloud setup
it supports both Amazon and Google and
even as ur if you want one its
maintained by Google itself and we even
have engineers from Google working on it
here and Microsoft and other companies
as you can see here we have an
application this is real production
traffic and in one page we can see our
application running both in Amazon and
in Google we don't need to worry about
it we don't need to figure out where
it's running and we can also see that
one instance out of those a hundred
twenty shards we have in Amazon is
misbehaving so we can terminate it
easily or I'll just killing will
automatically we don't need to worry
about it
spinnaker also allows us to have
automatic pipelines in one single
pipeline we can upgrade the binary and
configuration in both environments we
don't need to worry about it
it's just one click that pipeline
produces or actually executes more
pipelines underneath each pipeline has
canary testing and fast rollback in case
there is a problem in the canary that
way our developers can deploy fast
without worrying about if this decode is
stable or not if you want to learn more
about continuous deployment and how we
use spinnaker in our production traffic
system actually I recommend you sign up
for my session that my colleague is
giving on Friday let's talk about
spinnaker now earlier I've talked about
the outage Amazon had in 2015 I'm sure
most of you will recognize the headline
this was just last week they just gave
me more material for my work I guess so
in 2015 we barely survived that outage
our engineers work very hard to maintain
ourselves but here we were just fine
because we've implemented those
principles we've defined ourselves we
have multi-cloud and we are not bounding
ourselves to a single provider so in
case one goes down we're just launching
instances in the next one and a lot of
companies did go down but we didn't
I want to summarize a few things that
we've learned along the way I think
those will be valuable to you don't look
at it as a huge migration of a
multi-million company or a multi-million
user company look at it as a service by
service basis you might find that you
have any standalone services that you
can just as easily migrate them without
worrying about those big blocks that
have 500 dependencies or dozens of
dependencies and you can start saving up
just because you've moved that part and
if you find that you evaluate GCP and
you can't run that service on disappea
just wait it might get better and I know
it because we've done this for the past
three years and we've been constantly
evaluating GCP until hit it has reached
the point where we're saying ourself
this is the right moment it's ready for
us let's move
so what's next for us we are continuing
our migration and we're hoping to finish
it this year we're also looking at how
we can actually utilize GCPs
infrastructure for better our service to
improve this our service for end users
and our redundancy and as I said earlier
our users matter eventually we're doing
it for them just not because we want to
run on JCP or on AWS i want to finish
off with this image that i found which
kind of reminds me of how I feel with
this migration imagine you're going to
the same arcade shop every day for the
past years playing the same video games
every day and then there's a new arcade
shop across the street who won't want to
try that it has new air and different
games so you'll enjoy that but that
doesn't mean you have to only use that
new shiny arcade shop you can use both
what happens if there's a power failure
than you want you can go back to the
other one you'll just think for your
company and for your users what seems to
be the most luggage logic thing to do
and go with your heart
because that's what we did and we feel
more confident that our service is more
redundant today and resilience to any
outage that we'll have
I want to thank you for your time and
for taking for being here and for
learning everything on GCP so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you